it has been
10 years since you played a catwoman
okay
we saw you know zoe has now played her i
saw you commented on her instagram i was
wondering if you've seen the new batman
yet and what do you think of zoey so i
have been doing this so i haven't been
able to go to see it yet but i have a
friend who um saw it this weekend
and said not only
is she phenomenal in it but how much fun
it was to be in a packed movie theater
and realizing that people are coming
back to movies and droves and how great
it was to celebrate that so i'm so happy
for her um and i haven't had a chance to
see it yet so but i look forward to that
what do you care about
remember you had a past
make a business out of that feeling we
need a name we
we live we dream
we work
you and jared your chemistry just jumps
off the screen how did you two develop
that i don't know if you knew each other
from beforehand but their their love
comes through so much
um thank you thank you so much i'm so so
relieved to hear that um i've i had met
jared and uh but we've nev we never
hung out and um i'm a huge admirer of
his work
and i'd love to say that there was
something specific that we did that we
i don't know went to a yoga class
together we hung out we had coffee all
this stuff but
um but that didn't happen he came to set
as
adam and i met him as rebecca
and it was just and it was there and the
best thing that and what we kind of
agreed to do um without speaking about
it was we just kind of got out of the
way
and these two characters have such an
intensity to their relationship and we
just sort of honored that
in between action and cut and then
in between takes we just kind of kept it
very calm and loving and not much chit
chat but it was all very um supportive
and then you know we would just connect
every couple weeks just be like i'm so
grateful i'm just so grateful to be for
this whole experience it was just
beautiful it was really fun and
beautiful i have a responsibility to
think bigger i'm a golden goose land
golden eggs he
nails the the accent and the hair
he's good
he's no slouch that jared leto
what was your reaction when you first
met him as adam it just all felt very
true
and and also um jared just set such a
high bar for himself so when he walked
in in a way it was he was the part of
the series i was waiting for him i just
thought okay it was like a tuning fork
or something i just like i just i just
felt something open inside of me and i
just thought okay that's what we're
aiming for we're going wow we're
let's do it let's let's let's do this
there were times when we would be acting
in a scene and i'm just like it just
feels like we're free falling right now
it's amazing it was wild
and uh i just really loved it i loved it
are you a maverick or a muse amuse tell
me about your goals
i want to be in vanity fair
vanity fair's not for muses
then i want to change my answer and of
course you you know you're playing this
real person as well of course rebecca
and
changing your voice a little bit and
getting her mannerisms what kind of
research did you do to play her and to
nail her
well i work with a wonderful researcher
called amy hammond and she was really
integral in in terms of doing a lot of
the heavy lifting of the research into
rebecca's life and what her world is
like
rebecca spoke in a lot of interviews
about certain books that uh had a big
influence in her so i made sure that i
read those and i just would have tried
to you know she's someone who so
identifies as a spiritual person so i
tried to really get to know her
um that way but at the end of the day i
just i was i was one member of a team
and i i just really trusted the writing
and hoped that i was doing uh
doing her justice she's a an actress and
in some parts you have to act as an
actor acting was that a
what's that like what i uh wanted to
show because i i'm not a fan of saying
that someone's a good actor or a bad
actor i think that that's unhelpful and
god knows we all have days where we're
in the pocket and days when we're really
not
um but i i think that i what i wanted to
show is someone who maybe was tr
attempting things somebody who thought
they could do things that maybe they
didn't quite have the skills to do yet
he's also a yoga instructor are you a
yogi or did you need to brush up on your
yoga i'm much better now than i was yo
i've been i've been kind of uh
practicing inconsistently for a long
time but i had to get really serious in
order to play this part and um i wound
up doing it almost daily for months and
months and months and months and then we
got to the scene where rebecca is
teaching a yoga class
and the scene ended and my yoga
instructor who came to set that day
turned to me she's like so tomorrow and
i'm like oh no we're i'm in i'm in i
love this now so i so even
post series even after the series was
finished i've i've continued on with it
i actually had a class with her this
morning oh awesome yeah i'm really glad
i had spoken to kyle about how he also
met jared as adam and he told a very
sweet story about how they finally after
filming like went rock climbing and oh
he met jared i'm so jealous
i'm really i'm i'm waiting for my
meeting jared moment we but to be to be
fair we do we do text and we are in
communication and so i i have a text
relationship with jared but yeah i'm
hoping to meet him one of these days he
seems like a wonderful person
i hope that happens i think we're doing
the premiere so it's gonna happen there
right at some point at some point he and
i will be in the same place as ourselves
um there are so many great uh
takeaways from the show i i wondered
what you know as you got to play this
really layered person did you have a
takeaway from the script and from these
characters i find that like if i try to
do that i'm i find it really hard to act
i can't step outside the part enough to
imagine what's the takeaway or what
what's the message or what my people
feel about it but one of the things i
read in a book that was about a
spiritual practice that rebecca was very
interested in was judge all persons
favorably and that was how i approached
playing her because we all know how it
ended um we all know some of the stories
that came out about it but i just
thought what if
what if she really was a sincere person
with good intentions and the execution
of that fell short of what she was
hoping for that's
that's heartbreaking and i can relate to
that and um
and that's a really interesting
character and it it felt much less um
i don't know it felt like
it was more in line with the way i try
to live my life i'm not interested in
judging anybody or humiliating anybody
or dragging anybody or any of that stuff
i'm just a human being and and so she
and and it felt like a way of
approaching playing someone like that he
has my love i'll meet you in the car
okay sure you're ready yes yes
my love you're not wearing a shirt
would somebody grab me a shirt